BELL SKILLS CHALLENGE.
THERE IS GARLAND.
ONE SHOT.
>> MOBLEY.
OH!
EVAN MOBLEY!
IT'S A WINNER!
THE SECOND SHOT!
EVAN MOBLEY WINS IT FOR TEAM
CAVS.
>> I TOLD YOU THE CAVS!
CLEVELAND!
THIS IS FOR YOU, CLEVELAND!
THIS IS FOR YOU!
>> OH, MAN.
CLEVELAND, WE LOVE OUR LOCATION.
>> HEY, GIVE HIM ROOKIE OF THE
YEAR NOW.
GIVE EVAN MOBLEY THE TROPHY NOW.
HE MIGHT AS WELL HAVE IT
PRESENTED IT TO HIM NOW.
I KNOW, SCOTTIE, IT HURTS.
I WAS PUTTING MY LIP BALM ON,
REGGIE, I THOUGHT IT WAS GOING
TO BE A WHILE OVER HERE.
>> OH, MAN.
>> WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT WAS FUN.
THAT WAS GOOD.
WAY TO HEAT THE PLACE UP.
>> PRACTICE ENDS ON HALF-COURT
SHOTS.
WHY NOT THE SKILLS CHALLENGE?
TEAM CAVS.
THAT WAS LIKE WHAT COACH COME
IN, REG, HE SAY IF YOU HIT THIS
SHOT, YOU CAN GET OUT OF THE
PRACTICE.
THAT'S WHAT THAT FELT LIKE RIGHT
THERE.
>> OR AT THE END OF PRACTICE,
YOU MIKE THIS, YOU'VE GOT TO
COME IN.
>> YOU COME IN LATE BEFORE THE
GAME.
HAVE TO DO SHOOT AROUND.
>> NO SHOOT AROUND.